ha sido una sorpresa en un evento donde
siempre escasean nadie esperaba que la
asamblea nacional popular nombrara hoy
de nuevo a gigan al frente del Banco
Central de China primero porque en el
congreso del partido de octubre dejó de
formar parte del comité central segundo
porque ha alcanzado ya la edad oficiosa
de jubilación y tercero porque no forma
parte del núcleo duro de fieles del
presidente sizeping y de hecho va a
contrapelo en el pasaje de la alta
política china tiene una pasta
experiencia internacional y de hecho
vivió más de 10 años en Estados Unidos
primero estudiando el doctorado de
economía y después ejerciendo de
profesor en la prestigiosa universidad
de Illinois es por tanto una de las más
rutilantes tortugas marinas que es como
se conoce aquí en China a los que
regresan después de haber estudiado
fuera G es un firme defensor de las
reformas del mercado y evita las grandes
inversiones En infraestructuras para
batear las crisis en su hoja de
servicios a éxitos como haber mantenido
la inflación el año pasado en un 2%
cuando el resto del mundo y
especialmente occidente batía Records de
los últimos 40 años su reelección se
entiende Como una apuesta segura en unos
momentos en los que la economía china no
está para experimentos